direction cannes à présent pour le
festival deuxième journée de compétition
en lice habemus papam film de nanni
moretti qui signe le retour de michel
piccoli et puis la belle surprise du
jour c'est celle de maïwenn la jeune
réalisatrice française avec son film
polisse nous plonge dans le quotidien de
la brigade de protection des mineurs
un film très applaudi nathalie et terre
et olivier tu y es tu allé voir un psy
on pense à une bande de très bons
copains ils le sont un peu dans la vie
ils le sont surtout dans ce film polisse
deux heures au coeur de la brigade de
protection des mineurs deux heures en
immersion totale dans un monde policier
plutôt méconnu beaucoup de femmes de
solides amitiés et des affaires souvent
glauques raquette prostitution
pédophilie alors ça tu nous dis qu'ils
exploitent
et puis tant on protège on fait dans un
foyer et après un meeting soit tu dis
rien tu continues comme ça tu fais du
bic pocket encore pas mal en pis dans un
an comme tu es plutôt innate foot sur 38
la cuisson une fiction tourné comme un
documentaire passionnant et truffé
d'informations recueillies pendant
plusieurs mois par la réalisatrice
c'est le temps que j'ai passé là bas la
brigade qui m'a donné envie d'écrire
longtemps sur eux et 2
me plonger dans le plus possible dans
leur tête quoi de plus passer du temps
avec eux et tous les moments du jour et
de la nuit plus j'arrivais à à
comprendre comment il fonctionnait va
voir contre des photos critique la cage
du côté des mômes qui plaît tant
qu'homme c'est quoi c'est pas que ça
fait c'est plus complexe fait ça au
quotidien parallèle à genoux et puis
ouais je pense qu'il faut être un peu
écorché de le faire aussi le film
polisse a d'ores et déjà été salué par
la critique alors qu'en sera-t-il du
deuxième film présenté aujourd'hui
officiellement en compétition avaient
mousse papam de nanni moretti avec
michel piccoli dans le rôle du pape un
pape pas franchement comme les autres
puisqu'il refuse son élection en proie
au doute à la peur aux regrets il
s'échappe même du vatican
un papa la sauce moretti un carnet de
beaucoup de finesse par michel piccoli
je m'amuse de tout aussi bien des
personnages sérieux que des personnages
fait ans yeux que des personnages
qu'aucun je suis au matou faire voilà un
homme qui n'avait jamais tourné avec
nanni moretti son choix le réalisateur
italien ne l'a pas regretté pour lui
travailler avec michel piccoli fut selon
ses propres termes un vrai cadeau